it's time now for CBS deals spring is
finally here and this morning we have a
few products that just might help you
shake off those winter gold drums and
all the exclusive low prices we love
that to start shopping now scan that QR
code on your screen or visit
cbsdeals.com lifestyle expert Ashley
Bellman joins us with Morgan glad to
have you back so happy to be here happy
spring oh my God I'm happy women's
History Month we're still celebrating
that's right we're starting out with a
clean hair care line this is briogio
Nancy twine is the founder she was the
youngest African-American to launch a
brand at Sephora has gone on to win
countless Awards and it makes sense
because all of these products all sold
separately savings up to 33 off today
they're all incredible that one went
viral on Tick Tock that's the serum
that's going to make your hair thicker
everything something for everyone there
it is you have to get your hands on this
use it a couple times a week then you
also have the mask that's going to just
make your hair so hydrated curly hair
girls are something for you we can
detangle de-frizz and then the scallop
scrub here I just want you to feel the
texture of this the savings are amazing
today these are all sold separately but
16 is where the deals start that whipped
texture the smell is incredible and
clean products well it's important
because I have really dry hair and so
moisture especially this time and this
time of year is key how much are we
talking so 33 off up to 33 off or the
savings today 16 are what the prices
start at wrap them up definitely get
these all of them okay hydration
hydration hydration yes okay so none of
us drink enough water throughout the day
this is drink this is going to help us
all stay hydrated this water bottle is
the only water bottle you need I love
that it comes with the thermal sleeve to
keep the water cold a strap so I can
wear this out wear this hiking wear this
to the gym there's a spot for my phone
there's pockets for my cards and it's a
half gallon so this is all the water you
need to drink throughout the day and it
really keeps you on track because
there's notches along the side and I
love the handle because it's easy to tip
back if you want to drink it that way
there's also a straw option so there's
definitely here you go yeah there we go
oh thank you there's that straw that's
that's the key it's so comfy and you can
change the strap and make it into a
backpack this is 39.99 today it's 50 off
so get one for you get one for your
sister and I love all the different
colors I know because then I spill it
all away I like the straw too but
options for everyone if you like the tip
back we have that too it is I love that
39.99 and it comes with the cleaner as
well and that's 50 off 50 off we love
that okay this is a game changer I just
have to say I haven't tried this but
this is incredible I have sheets are all
about if you want to feel like you're
waking up in the luxurious Hotel
Jennifer Adams linens are what you need
also celebrating women's History Month
with Jennifer 25 off these beautiful
sheets feel them do they not feel like
butter do they not feel like you are at
a resort and they feel like this as soon
as you put them on your bed and get this
they get softer as you wash them
breathable great if you have sensible
sensitive skin and a sensible book that
you're reading in your in your luxury
hotel Shameless promotion there I love
it but this is great and chemical free
these are the sheets that you need it
comes in different sizes starting at
113.99 today these are 25 off their 400
thread count love so super soft and but
this is how they are coming out of bag
and the fact that you watch them and
they get it's softer a little bit that
doesn't happen often yeah no that's
important I love sheets Like That Ashley
again thank you so much and of course we
partner with all of these companies get
these great deals to buy anything you
saw today just scan that QR code on your
screen or head on over to cbsdeals.com